thank you
dude when we filmed uh the jackass movie
the first movie that you know um the
scene where where we were in the Hummer
going through the desert and they're
[ __ ] tattooing the the off-road
tattoo yeah it's Henry Rollins in the
movie but it was supposed to be Nikki
supposed to be Nikki Sixx and and I mean
like they told me it was gonna be Nikki
Six right and so I show up for that
shoot we're in the desert wherever we're
gonna film this [ __ ] thing right and
I'm sitting there just like every other
day on that goddamn River just doing
[ __ ] blow except on this day I've got
my framed picture of me as a little kid
with Nikki Sixx and I'm just [ __ ]
working lines off of it
like I said as if Nicky's gonna be
really impressed by that
dude was totally sober already
like yeah cool
[ __ ] Kook but uh then uh but then
they were like there's your hero Nikki
sex [ __ ] and and they went up to they
sent me up to them and Rollins got out
and I thought of the Ramones because
it's gonna beat me up because
hooking up with this chick that always
flew out to be with Rollins and like she
told me about like all these like crazy
rolling stories you know and then I'm on
Howard Sterns we've been talking I've
brought the chick on Howard Stern and
was like bringing up Rollins you know
like so like that bro that had already
all happened at the point when like they
go go up to the SUV and Robin's gonna so
I thought the bit was that Rollins was
gonna beat me up in the movie you know
oh my God yeah but he was just super
cool yeah did he even mention like he
did it okay nothing professional and
then when my book came out uh and my
book came out the the writer like did an
interview with Rollins and Rollins said
that he just didn't even [ __ ] hadn't
even ever heard about it you know I I
good answer dude yeah
yeah
dude